do you guys want to do an inverse
game-mode what does that mean do you
guys want to fight a juggernaut zombie
yes I'm gonna make it 64 humans but the
max players is the zombies are gonna be
basically invincible oh they're gonna be
so much scarier than before like hold on
to your poops more scarier yes I might
actually make it one zombie because
every human that dies is gonna become a
zombie joke oh yeah it's gonna be two
juggernaut zombies to begin with and the
humans just need to stay away from them
for 20 minutes that's probably gonna
work right yeah should be fine you guys
ready to probably just die and for this
to be not as fun as I hope it will yeah
yeah I guess we don't have to hide our
screens on this one cuz the zombies
don't give [ __ ] they're just gonna kill
everyone by touching all right you
didn't have to tell me twice
dude as soon as you said we didn't have
to
I was already showing it I was already
not I don't know if this is gonna go the
way we think it is but I think it's
going to be this weird like very
accurate simulation of what is our be
about which would be where the humans
don't stand a chance we're all dumbasses
we think for the first ten minutes it's
fine and then there's a that's true the
moment one of the zombies finds more
than like five humans in one spot oh
we're just [ __ ]
we're totally [ __ ] go our luck is
gonna be we land right where the zombies
are yeah wherever wherever both of them
are that's definitely where we're going
can we just stay here this is delightful
yeah this is a really relaxing way to
spend the first five minutes of the
round I think this is a parachute sweet
pineapple bro oh you got the orange one
that's a good one
it's a classic I've that I have this
sick like green one dude that is that's
a
it's the green one if you see a zombie
on the ground don't kill him don't just
don't we the four of us together if we
were all shooting it with the best guns
we could find couldn't kill it before it
could kill all of us cuz all the humans
need to work together just like they
realize we'll split up it's fine
this is a lesson in how not to behave
right so what I'm hearing is we don't
engage for the love of God wait please
wait why no right yeah no if you see him
at a distance definitely let us know and
then start shooting and that way your
death might give us all a chance to get
away okay I are you Alpha from Power
Rangers no I was perfect alpha what did
you get here okay okay Rick it's me Rick
Wow alpha Rick there's no point of our
stage kit because if we get hit we're
dead right you don't get one shot but I
think it's probably two shots oh yeah
that's plus you do regenerate health you
do actually regenerate health so if you
can get away that's basically your best
chance at survival anyway Oh bad
who's shooting oh god I'm coming to you
guys okay we have names above our heads
do you guys got another vehicle for B
they took it oh [ __ ] we need to steal
one of the vehicles so that way mark are
not left alone friend here with a with
the vehicle I'm hopping in don't trust
them don't trust them oh boy Mark's
going for ride I'm going for my ride
team's stranger danger I know it's fine
I trust this person whoever this is so
that's a bush dammit wait where are you
going I'll cover it okay goodbye
find you wait get in alright alright so
frustratedly wait get in the car guys
guys I don't want to alarm you but the
zombie number is 25 right now oh no
something horrible has happened
God so many zombies it's 26 wait we're
not going to the northeast part of the
circle that's where the zombies we had
so many guards before sorry alright
sorry I'm looking at the map sorry oh
god no oh sweet Jesus honestly I can
only pull flee towards the yellow mark
flee towards the yellow mark with
motorcycles then yeah that's a bad one
with my blue dot blue dot if we can blow
up the car they might want to fetch this
buggy that okay wheel bike is really
hard to drive again for our friends so
they don't have to drive the shitty bike
guys
20:28 not it for once it's not pub G
okay hold on is it 187
oh okay this is working now I'm going to
just try to avoid potted plants we're
trying guys 32 versus 30 right now oh
that's so not good it's multiple zombies
zombies hang on can I or so do fuel Oh
fuel Bob fuel / fine
I'm conserving unconcerned zombies in
the road Bob I got a bad feeling they're
coming for us one's gonna read our mark
we need to steal the buggy okay ready
I'm ready here we go
[Applause]
[ __ ] this is a disaster
oh god I feel kind of funny guys are you
dead I'm a zombie yeah I'm dead of
course I'm okay are you guys still alive
yeah it's a miracle
blowing up the car
hey listen mr. zombie face yeah you'll
never get us Wow just the burning
wreckage of a buggy you know
on the map open up your map oh that's
our guys those are our guys no you can
see red dots on the map I don't see red
dots I just saw them a second ago now
they're gone
wait what was that it's because your
server host meeting are you cheating Bob
where are you guys guys wait that we
survived we survived so fine right you
don't know her
this is a different map yeah there's
snow on this one yeah I'm just trying to
help you guys we go back so far guys
we're yes stays that far back
we are such good friends I love you I
see these one red dots appearing your
eyes are broken well come help your
sidewalk good job was killing myself
thank you I'm really glad you got on
your own vehicles in order to die
whatever
[Laughter]
or why are you so down what's going on
you okay over there
you only have two minutes left
oh thank god oh man only two minutes to
show everyone how fun it is to be in the
circle you know up here good done there
bad I've got a great shot of my ass
right now what happened 30 seconds the
humans just survive and win yeah it's
all good seconded we should do that
again with no vehicles then the humans
are so pwned no lower the health by a
look like a little make the zombies more
reasonable yeah yeah like like you could
one on one one if you had distance on it
so the difference in this one is no
vehicles slightly lower zombie kill
ability and bigger balls let's go kill
the goat man watch out for snakes and
landmine churches naked and then didn't
get my clothes back before the things so
no I'm the naked one zombies go for the
naked one first I was in the kitchen
washing a dish of a Dean cook
impersonation isn't it
hmm are we I guess we're here we go
there's marks in the map go look we're
gonna coordinated I'm glad that everyone
on the plane waited to go right here
with us there's plenty of loot in this
city for every survivor oh you know what
I didn't turn vehicles off oh god damn
it
get out oh god someone's killing sub
etang why are they dying though somebody
killed his ambi I think hell yeah yay
got him missed it squished on my screen
so I'm pretty satisfied with it well if
it didn't happen on mine then it's I
guess we'll never know
Oh am i dying hello I'm back in the game
apparently I don't know how Volta mark
you should go into the zone where are
you guys
guys you getting away from you at full
speed are there no vehicles on this map
so I'm sure the zombies already have
them all 17 zombies huh yeah that's
probably good those zombies are really
killable though so just like shoot Adam
you'll be fine all right cool good I got
bullets I'm gonna take the bridge
because zombies might be under water
ready to nibble at my too it's
terrifying
they can't we go swimming in the water
and they're all behind me and tell me if
I'm close Bob take my compliment I got
it I got it cool that you want my
backpack no I don't I've got a big thing
is level while mine is cooler though
it's just cool yeah well they just
killed someone only 17 alive right now
17 is not a good number of zombies
they're not this super this time but yes
they respawn how much health and how
much damage resistance are we doing they
have like 350 health this time users
Christ that's the it was 500 last time
and they also have like how many they
have like 50% damage reduction
this time and last time they had like
90% damage reduction okay there are way
more killable
all right you're right way more killable
they have already been killed
I'm like killable zombies okay okay
right next to you guys so far I think
was just someone silly on this can't
hurt you okay I've got so much ammo and
I know I'm gonna die I want to pick you
with a little good scooter do you like
it who's on who's um
there we go that's right sorry thank you
for getting off I appreciate your what
are we about to do what do we I thought
you had a plan I thought you well I mean
the way you said that was very
suspicious I thought you were like
detergent deserve either so that what
that's dupit why would I do that
I don't know cuz you're an idiot that's
true but can I get on and I hey let me
on give me a ride hey come on everyone
hop on okay okay well there's only 14
Dom bees left you know I feel like this
is cheating know what whoa whoa Jesus
somebody tried to blow up our scooty Oh
more zombies seem to be happening we're
at nine teams are eight now we went from
14 to 19 just now well I think that was
a respawn wave oh we're at 20 okay well
that's not what you want to see it
there's someone dying getting hurt dead
ahead of us at 1:45 oh that's a yeah
they're down can we save them Oh actual
fighting happening where [ __ ] are they
coming through those shots were by me I
think it was actual killing a zombie oh
I don't like the fog the fog is too
scary this airs dummy thick there are
zombies north of me and Wade right now
okay okay just to let you know you guys
are last straggling off the you're last
are they down in the rice fields I don't
know they're like north and or northeast
of us but I have no idea where no it's
just like ma'am
oh god who are they shooting at I don't
know I can't see anything that is a lot
of [ __ ] guns a lot of bullets dad oh
no there's a zombie tuk-tuk the zombies
have vehicles be careful okay they don't
okay another down okay this is handle it
only took 50 of us to take that get up
there get off he'll come down to us Bob
there's one right here on me I see I see
I see I see I'm trying to save this [ __ ]
ah damn it
okay I've got you I've got you covered
oh they respond they respond already
holy [ __ ] wait they just respawn right
next to you they respawn where they die
oh okay I want you to go yeah we need to
go you sure do Oh God they knock someone
no no we need two guys coming from our
left
yeah zombies coming it's close super
hurt super hurt I've got four shots and
you get better - oh my god
going going going going where did they
come from
why did where's our group blue zone go
to the zone the Blues coming you guys
guys hey it's not so bad are you dead no
of course not
what are you talking about no not very
thirsty though yeah well just two in
front of us Bob we're just refund right
near you wait wait wait wait I think
Wade's unmuted forever we need to keep
moving we need to keep moving
yeah away from us oh my god there's so
many around Wade
holy [ __ ] no we gotta get out of here we
gotta get out here what do you mean guys
oh my god they take so much [ __ ] ammo
to kill I am gonna run out of ammo this
is not good
is in a truck why are you white can you
can you guys here wait because I cannot
I can here wait oh I cannot here wait
oh my god really are you [ __ ] serious
Oh God
wait talk can you hear me talk talk talk
there you are I got you hey buddy I want
to kill some humans one don't kill me
I'm your friend I smell them I smell
pennies all right that's a little weird
but okay hey they're in a truck I wish I
was on a squad with you zombie friends
the Sun that's not fun time oh yeah
we're in difference oh my god wait are
you still alive this truck yeah yeah I'd
like 30 of us are chasing a human's 52
zombies I don't know if this is gonna
like just arrived two minutes that I see
one in the open here not even a where oh
damn there's buildings there and they're
in buildings you guys can just rush them
down which building it's awfully
convenient we can jump to the second
floor of the build I mean the mannequin
building what the hell no mark behind
you they're in there that's the one
there the truck it was scary
what's with the mannequins this or
buying it where's this truck hey true
Northwest he's right next to us if we
clog up the tires with our bodies they
can't possibly survive eat yourself to
the machine there's some more hiding
somewhere we got to scour these
buildings
yeah there's only two in the truck
interesting interesting Oh God oh I
almost the prompt to get in showed up I
could have gone into oh yeah yeah you
gotta get in yes gonna call their eyes
out got punch me back in heat he's got
to run out of gas eventually
damnit that is a human vehicle there's
two there's two human vehicles and
they're the ones who are left we're not
going to get it in time yeah I tried it
didn't work I think they have to be
stopped to get in ah damn it oh yeah I
got the prompt but I didn't make it in
minute respawn timer both times up oh
man man vehicle should have been turned
off that search Bob you killed three
people
oh yeah I did it man Bob you did it well
booty shorts I got one kill Wow hell
yeah Wow I got one kill - nice mark how
many kills you get buddy I didn't check
ten yep where you are killer fan eighty
nothing yes you're him oh yeah you got
lots of kills buddy good job thank you
yeah that sounds like he didn't get it
how are you good no know what to do
triple digits there was a zero in the
number
[Music]
you